primeiro gostaria de dizer que estou
muito feliz muito feliz por estar aqui
hoje conversando com vocês
conversando sobre educação criatividade
e tecnologia
mas eu não vim aqui pra contar sobre uma
nova ferramenta um novo aplicativo ou
uma nova forma de atuar em sala de aula
porque isso tem na internet tem no
google em buscas
eu vim aqui pra compartilhar um jeito
que eu encontrei de impactar
positivamente a nossa área da educação e
esse jeito hoje ele só acontece porque
ele está conectado por três pontos serão
os que eu vou compartilhar com vocês
também
eu sempre gostei muito de conversar
muito
quando eu era criança eu adorava mas
ainda espelho de classe sabem aquele ela
estratégia que os professores utilizavam
para separar a gente era a coisa que eu
mais gostava de fazer era a oportunidade
que eu via de burlar o sistema e fazer
novos amigos e conhecer novas pessoas e
brincar mais
mas isso tinha um preço e esse preço
ele vinha trimestralmente com o tipo de
informação no meu boletim seja tenta
evitando conversar e ouvir brincadeiras
aguarde a sua vez de falar e eu tinha
que levar isso para casa e voltar com a
assinatura do meu pai e eu fico
imaginando se coloquem no meu lugar
vocês já pararam para pensar o quanto é
difícil dizer por uma criança de seis
anos não conversar e não brincar
então pense em quantas vezes a gente faz
isso com o uso do celular e uso do
tablet em que eles passam a maior parte
da vida deles do zero aos quatro anos em
casa assistindo todos os tipos de
programação escolhendo o que fazem e
chegam lá na sala de aula e simplesmente
agora isso não pode mais
pense e hoje
hoje eu trabalho conversando
eu sou professora eu sou pedagoga sou
designer de aprendizagem e esse é o meu
trabalho eu dou aula manhã tarde noite
conversando com os meus alunos
então o primeiro ponto que conecta esse
jeito que eu encontrei de impactar de
realmente fazer a diferença é por meio
da conversa e por isso eu digo pra vocês
está aberta a temporada da conversa
conversa
ano passado eu recebi um convite de uma
amiga por e mail pra fazermos um
processo seletivo de um curso que o
google estava oferecendo para trabalhar
com tecnologias educacionais e eu estava
cheio de coisas para fazer naquele
momento tinha prova para corrigir tinha
aluno para orientar de um monte de
coisas para fazer um processo por
extenso tinha uma série de etapas para
cumprir
na verdade eu estava morrendo de medo de
fazer porque eu tenho pavor de processo
seletivo de provas de avaliação e eu
estava com medo de fazer mas aí eu tive
uma série de amigos que me disseram não
que medo de onde isso esse curso têm
tudo a ver contigo precisa fazer e ok
vamos lá e foram dois dias incríveis
conversando com pessoas sensacionais
pensando as maiores coisas malucas para
impactar a educação e para trabalhar com
tecnologias em sala de aula
no final do curso eu tive que fazer um
plano de ação um plano de aula para
impactar alunos
só que eu não queria impactar alunos
porque os alunos eles já nascem sabendo
usar as tecnologias
eu não vejo tanta necessidade de focar
nos alunos
mas eu vejo a necessidade de impactar os
professores que são aqueles que não são
os nativos digitais e eu queria impactar
alguém de uma forma grandiosa impactar o
mundo e mudar o mundo
só que eu não vi essa idéia assim tão
rápida
até que de repente surge uma poll
a tese de uma ideia e eu compartilhei
com as pessoas que estavam ali na minha
volta
olha pensando isso que tu acha super
legal em porto alegre isso acontece eu
claro óbvio que acontece
tá então toma fazer e quando a gente
pensa em trabalhar com formação de
professores é um trabalho bastante com
formação de professores hoje a gente
imagina algo do tipo vamos levar os
professores para o laboratório de
informática para fazer uma oficina e eu
não queria fazer oficina eu queria fazer
algo diferente e eu compartilhei nas
redes sociais
a idéia lá mesmo no curso para ver se
colava se realmente fazia sentido uma
idéia
convidei a galera pra ir pra redenção
pra conversar sobre tecnologias cada um
levava sua tecnologia seu tablet seu
smartphone
vamos lá conversar vamos ver o que
acontece até porque naquele período eu
não queria que essa discussão ficasse
centralizada apenas nas instituições que
o trabalho hoje eu queria que realmente
mais pessoas pudessem compartilhar em
poucos minutos a galera curtiu porque
enquanto eu estava lá estava todo mundo
conta aí o que tá fazendo está
aprendendo enfim ea galera curtiu e
daiane vão para o parque vamos conversar
ea galera foi no dia marcado
alguns estão aqui a galera foi a galera
foi conversar sobre tecnologias no
parque porque o que eu tinha imaginado
na google era chamar de chimarrão no
parque bom vou convidar os amigos para
tomar chimarrão ea gente já conversa
sobre tecnologia já compartilha faz tudo
e a coisa começou a crescer e de pedir
chimarrão no parque passou a se chamar
chefe piquenique para além dos muros da
sala de aula porque a gente pode sim
trabalhar com tecnologias sem ser no
laboratório de informática sem ser
dentro da escola a gente pode explorar
outros espaços
por isso o segundo ponto que conecta
esse jeito que eu encontrei foi por meio
dos meus amigos porque esse projeto esse
sonho ele só deu certo em função dos
meus amigos que comparecer
ser um ano para que aquele dia eu
sozinha não ia conseguir fazer nada eles
estavam lá por isso façam amigos façam
amigos dos amigos hoje são de extrema
relevância para a gente tocar qualquer
projeto desses adiante
lá no google a galera pirou adoraram a
idéia
mandaram aqui o e mail inacreditável em
porto alegre as pessoas realmente fazem
piquenique para falar sobre tecnologias
como isso e lá eles me convidaram para
participar de um outro projecto que se
chama grupo de educadores google grupo
de educadores google é um movimento
global mundial todo mundo pra falar
sobre educação e tecnologias são
professores apaixonados por educação e
querem fazer a mudança por meio das
tecnologias e aí a gente fundou o grupo
de educadores google porto alegre no
final do ano passado
hoje a gente atua basicamente em três
frentes que são a o nosso site nós temos
um site specifics mas está em
desenvolvimento e que ele compartilha
todos os nossos sonhos tudo aquilo que a
gente acredita em como impactar a
comunidade as nossas redes sociais que
nós temos um time de colunistas de
amigos na verdade compartilhando
experiências aplicativos formas jeitos
de pensar como usar as tecnologias em
sala de aula e nós temos também um grupo
que a gente chama de grupo de mentores
que são pessoas que não são professores
não são da área da tecnologia em
especial da área de educação
muitos deles dizem que não têm de dar
dica mas como daí eu posso participar de
um grupo de professores sem ser
professoral center didática eles não têm
da típica talvez eles acreditam que não
têm onde da tijuca mas eles têm amor
eles acreditam eles ea gente tem um
propósito
a gente acredita que pode junto mudar
então assim são designers informatas
nerds enfim de todas as áreas realmente
querendo fazer a diferença aqui são
algumas das pessoas que estão
participando desse grupo
aqui eu trouxe pra mostrar pra vocês um
infográfico que mostra a evolução dos
nossos encontros no primeiro encontro
apareceram 21 pessoas somente minhas
amigas todos eles meus amigos todos me
conheciam
no segundo encontro a coisa começou a
crescer e começar a aparecer outras
pessoas que amigos dos amigos
no terceiro encontro a gente teve uma
baixa choveu e daí quando chove não dá
pra fazer piquenique no parque e ainda
assim algumas pessoas toparam vamos
fazer vamos com chuva mesmo
ok vamos lá e ainda assim pessoas que
não nos conheciam começaram a
compartilhar no nosso quarto encontro
nós tivemos pessoas vindo de fora de
porto alegre pessoas vindo de são paulo
pra ajudar para compartilhar boas
práticas e no nosso quinto encontro que
acontecerá amanhã
nós identificamos ao longo dessa pequena
trajetória que a gente tinha que focar
um pouco mais nos professores porque até
então nos piqueniques e nos parques
estavam vindo apenas pessoas que já mais
ou menos tinham interesse na área das
tecnologias ea gente queria mais a gente
quer mais a gente quer chegar realmente
nos professores que são as pessoas que
precisam e nós fechamos uma parceria com
uma escola pública de porto alegre
amanhã será a primeira vez que isso
acontece e serão 30 novas novos amigos
a nossa intenção é que isso cresça de
forma exponencial um dia serão 30 amigos
conversando sobre tecnologias 30 novos e
mais os 20 que atuam como mentores
então o nosso grupo está crescendo as
pessoas estão se envolvendo com isso
lá no grupo a gente vai falar também
além do uso das tecnologias porque a
gente acredita que não é só as
tecnologias que fazem esse movimento
a gente acredita em design de
aprendizagem então para além do uso das
tecnologias têm que ter sentido tem que
ter significado
então a proposta é que a gente mobiliza
os professores a pensar em empatia e em
colaboração em experimentação que eles
pensem em design para além de deixar
algo mais bonito em e alinhado não é
design no sentido de projetar algo
projetar situações de aprendizagem de
maneira que os alunos realmente aprendam
por meio de projetos e desafios e
construindo algo mão na massa mesmo
outro dia recebi um e mail de uma pessoa
que não é daqui de porto alegre querendo
implantar o grupo lá
bn como eu faço para implantar um grupo
de educadores aqui na minha cidade mas a
maior dúvida dele não era em relação a
toda a parte burocrática que tem que
fazer formulários tudo que tem que
defender não ele queria saber como que a
gente faz para engajar toda essa gente
num projeto voluntário em que ninguém
ganha nada e eu disse a ele olha ele é
um professor de administração
empreendedorismo enfim ele queria saber
que plano planejamento estratégico
utilizava e quais eram as nossas metas
até o final do melhor eu até tenho
vergonha de dizer isso porque na
realidade não tem plano nenhum não tem
cronograma a gente faz o encontro daí se
deu certo a gente planeja o próximo ea
gente vai vendo com os amigos que têm na
volta como que a gente faz o próximo mas
eu tenho algumas hipóteses para te dizer
o porque que tem tanto movimento assim
no grupo de porto alegre e as hipóteses
são primeiro que tu tens que ter amigos
porque só com os seus amigos que
realmente vai fazer a coisa acontecer
sinto não tem amigos que precisa
conversar então para fazer novos amigos
mas o que realmente eu acredito que
torna esse projeto essencial é que nós
temos um propósito
nós temos um propósito que é impactar e
que é transformar a educação
por isso vocês precisam sonhar e o
terceiro e terceiro ponto que conecta
esse jeito que a gente encontrou além de
conversar ter amigos é ter um propósito
é ter um sonho e nós temos esse sonho
que nos conecta esses são os três pontos
então se conectam esse projeto e eu
acredito que quando a gente quer ir
rápido a gente pode ir sozinho mas
quando a gente quer ir longe a gente
precisa dos amigos
então agora que nós já somos amigos eu
convido vocês a conversar mais e a
sonhar mais com a gente
tenho e obrigado